hey I'm Doug Walker from channel awesome
at the end of our most popular show
nostalgia critic we always do a charity
shout-out encouraging people to donate
well they've done well we realize not
everybody's in a financial situation
where they can give but everybody at
some point or another can give time so
every month we're gonna try and show a
new charity or organization that you can
help out with there's so many people in
difficult circumstances but thankfully
there's always people who are willing to
help and you can be one of them whether
it's volunteering or lending a helping
hand we're here to show you what you can
do hi my name is Bradley Johnson I'm the
director for a core programs here at
field and what does Bill do well
building the youth development
organization the purpose is to take
youth from Memphis to add hope to a
variety of programs whether it's arts
mentoring academics career readiness
college readiness and what event are we
at today well today this is somewhere
about fatuity 2018 this is our second
annual time hosting summer of
opportunity and this event is a
culmination of our desire to change the
narrative about the Austin community to
change the way we see ourselves the way
the largest city as a whole sees the
West Side and then the way the nation
sees our city as well as the notion that
we don't have anything some of
opportunity we have over 40 vendors 40
different organizations we have elected
officials police department schools
present here we have nonprofit
organization businesses here this is all
to display three things number one to
our parents who say that there's nothing
for the kids to do there's plenty here
within our communities for our kids to
do second to demonstrate to our city
Austin is a viable community and we're
powerful and we're strong and then
thirdly to display to our nation our
world
we get calls for interviews to say tell
us about violence
tell us about shootings and all that no
one wants to hear about the awesome
great things that are going on and
that's what so much opportunity is about
there's a display of the resources that
we have here within our community we
don't have to look outside for
everything that we need most of it is
already here and it's for us to activate
and use it and apply it and we'll see
transformation in our community we have
a great relationship with the 15
district and I hope that it can be
modeled across our city we're in Austin
right now baby
[Applause]
this is Austin and everyone just cheers
and they've grown they're so happy and
it's like yeah you can definitely feel
like the sense of community here and I
think seeing all these people come out
here and just have fun and like you know
go to a lot of tents and stuff like that
me that's got to be a good feeling for
you oh it's definitely a good feeling
you heard the roar because this doesn't
typically happen in our communities hold
event was born with Adam Alonzo he's our
executive director he had built and we
started talking about all the work that
we do we work with youth and I have over
25 years of experience working with
young people all the work we can do
means nothing if you can't transform the
community just sending them back into
what we don't do is turn youth away we
work with the youth that pretty much get
kicked out of school we work with the
youth that are referred by the juvenile
justice system we work with youth who
are not just at risk with their in gangs
we work to get them to touch from gangs
and through intensive mentoring many of
our staff were former participants and
so we try to carry it through but it's
through love there's still a commitment
to a focus of taking on young people
bringing up on with it I'll bring them
where they need to be keep a positive
attitude
you gotta see change cuz we
we're at a u.s. senator doing the wild
[Applause]
as I busted a few white man moves didn't
look that good and I hope that your
children are not watching while I was
out there dancing it'll be a terrible
thing for them to see seems like there's
good stuff I like the kids and the
parents and Jeff like that I meet just
seems like a good collection of just
good stuff this is very important this
is part of us changing the narrative
part of us seeing each other by bringing
all ages this is cross generational
cross-sector all these different groups
coming together and that's a display of
power that we have we also leverage this
to get information that's all we have
resource tables here as well because
many times people in the community who
need the services the most don't get it
we're so big that communication is an
issue so the people when they first come
in they gonna have to come back resource
table you got the stage at the very end
but when you come in there's all the
tents saying here's a bunch of other
exact coal stuffing and of the community
education business health care all
resources really can't flow in from
outside until we cultivate what we have
inside that's a major priority in our
community in our neighborhood village
over there so the health community is
coming
sho'nuff strong today in particular I
want to recognize the rental hospital
I'm very honored and pleased be the
present CEO deliver the hospital right
down the street here in Austin and what
are they doing at this event today we're
helping support the community and really
have the information about healthcare
there are a lot of disparities in
healthcare we want people to get well
our goal is improve the lifespan of the
community and others
that plagued the african-american
community I'm Angela Waller the director
of community engagement and strategic
partnerships for Loretta Hospital what
can people do to help out not only the
hospital but just their own health in
general definitely being mindful of
their health knowing what their
age-related screenings are you need to
know what types of screenings that you
need and also to make sure if you have
any types of family history that you get
your screenings early if necessary even
at the intro they were really pushing
big time you know just the importance of
health because some people Ryan you live
once let me just eat whatever I want to
do whatever I want stuff but I mean
there's so much to health especially cuz
you just feel better you move better you
just you get you get like them we also
have a portal so you can connect with
the hospital and get information we also
do videos that you go on our website and
see that information on the website so
it's about learning you know there's an
African proverb that says he who has
health has everything you want to keep
your body in shape so that way you can
do everything else in your life and
already Hospital has a lot of
comprehensive services including primary
care for people to come out and make
sure that they're healthy and definitely
able to do what they need to do in the
community downtown Chicago life
aspecting there's an idiot years of life
here next to 23 B 7 miles from downtown
at sixteen point two years of life so to
your point is 20 years difference in
seven miles of myself I've got to help
increase the education information and
diagnostic information for patients they
live long it's all about those social
determinants of health and we're making
sure providing all of those wraparound
services for the community it's
different than it was even ten years ago
this type of collaboration didn't really
happen but now you're gonna find in this
event people from Walt way up north
Austin and with South Austin there's
somebody from every part of the
community they are representing you
what's some of the most encouraging
stuff you've heard from
kids or parents or people that work
there just about building the impact
it's having well I don't want to use
swear words okay we use them all the
time on our channel my god how was that
a meeting to use violence and Safety
Committee they welcomed us because we
had kind of never been a part of the
program
it was like man we blew welcome bill
because bill gets done like our art
program blocks if you want it grew out
of the passion that I you have whatever
it takes for us to grab the attention of
a young person is what we do you got to
have them looking beyond 18 years old
and so we have education as well as a
mentoring as well as job development
career readiness life skills all these
things and social-emotional learning is
at the foundation of what we do
[Applause]
we share Austin but I am so proud today
to see all the community comes residents
and children join forces with the
providers the educators the families the
police the elected officials to bring
joy to the hearts of my young people on
that note you see so many people walk
around the yellow shirts I mean just
everywhere there's so many volunteers
that come and help out with building
this show is very much focused on what
volunteers can do what are some of the
things that volunteers can do it is a
fine bill they want to help whether it
be here or even just online oh what can
they do online and everything else get
the word out and share about Bill but
personally we have after-school programs
we can use support with mentoring
tutoring we have over 60 events every
year from family nights to events like
this year-round so we always need help
with that we have openings
positions we have employment
opportunities were build whether you're
a doctor or lawyer scientists we want
you to come and work with our kids if
you know how to spin a ball on your head
come and spin a ball in a head but show
a young person how to do it too every
new experience expands their brain and
when you expand their brain that's the
capacity to learn and grab hold of more
but it also breaks down those barriers
and those laws that they have that gives
them one more mile of hope it makes them
look beyond 21 years old because a lot
of young people you ask to play on the
streets how long you plan to live you
say 30 years old if I make it there they
tell my 25 maybe if were able to do that
now they could see themselves doing
something even just spin in a ball over
here
if people want to volunteer or they want
donate to the site or give any kind of
supporting way you look in the camera I
want you to say where they can go online
do Chicago or I look forward to seeing
you thank you thank you so much
so me and Doug are about to dominate
this wall but it's a race to see who
dominates it first
[Applause]
go
what's running from crap anyone anyone
you deserve that beanie bitch
I mean it's about the beanie babies I
love anything that I do it for the
beanie babies
next up next
you